[Applause]
you look amazing thank you yeah
thank you well let's go uh
i'd like your mood hair to be a little
higher yeah okay oh thank you
sorry now you made me self-conscious uh
it's never happened before um
welcome to the show good to have you
here again uh and i want to say
something first of all scrubs
uh i've talked to you about this before
but very funny show and you're very
funny on it
so are you oh thank you i'm not on that
show
[Laughter]
i don't know what the part would be but
i can run it at any point just salute
the camera and run off
done done uh now you've been doing this
show for
a while and it seems seems like how many
seasons has it been now has it been
we're on our fifth
fifth season that's hard to believe yeah
it's crazy and now i don't know if i'm
mistaken but it seems like they're
working animals into the show now
more than ever i've turned it a few
times it seems like they someone on the
show just
loves trying to get animals into the
script so that you guys have to interact
with an animal is that true
yeah and more this year than any other
season
i actually really want your evil puppy
on now who i'm kind of obsessed with
watch out for that puppy he seems people
go on
and then they burn in hell forever yeah
maybe not yeah
if we had this year like raccoons rats
um
a giant black bear ostriches jason
bateman comes on to play this ostrich
farmer okay
i've never been around an ostrich what's
an ostrich like well
the writers had just read somewhere that
um ostriches are actually the second
fastest animal next to a cheetah
right and they can kill someone with
their kick and so they read that and
they were like okay i guess we need to
write ostriches into the script because
that's the funniest thing i've ever
heard so you had to be around this
animal and was there a handler there
saying beware of his deadly kick or
something
yes and we actually also got warned that
if you actually get into a problem
with the ostrich you lie down on the
ground because they kick you and they
kill you because they can kick as hard
as a horse but they have
sharp claws on the end so they kick you
and then grab your heart and pull it out
and then show it to you and go right
exactly that's what they told us and but
if you lie down on the ground
they can only kick straight out and so
then if you're on the ground they can
just like
stomp on you a little bit see that's
terrible i i hate that every all the
advice
is always around whether it's a deadly
bear or in this case a killer ostrich
the advice is always
lay down in front of it and then half
the time those people get killed they're
like yeah
only works about half the time 50
survival rate so this is an ostrich
would just
jump up and down on top of you why
wouldn't his deadly claws then be able
to
pull your heart out from the other side
of your body
maybe maybe because like the it's the
force i don't know
thank you we've got to look into these
ostrich attacks
my favorite also advice is if a shark is
attacking you punch it in the nose
that's what they say is if a shark is
coming here you punch it in the nose and
i'm like yeah that's
great that's perfect because i really
would probably have like the like sense
of mind to be able to do that
yeah the shark would be like oh you just
hit me in the nose what can i do to get
you back
oh right giant jaw full of teeth
my biggest fear in life is actually
sharks sharks scare you yeah i wonder
who would win
a shark or an ostrich if they were
fighting i think the officers would win
right yeah let's get that on fox tv
let's see
um now okay i know that you grew up in
canada
and and i know a bit about you what i
didn't know is you're very well
educated you you speak is this true you
you're trilingual you speak english
obviously you speak
french and you speak german yeah my
parents were
crazy they thought it was a good idea if
my sisters and i went to school all day
with all of our classes in french and
then went to german school after school
so you learn you would speak french all
day yeah and then
uh and then learn german afterwards yeah
my uh my mom's family is german
and so we would speak german with my
grandmother and she lived like three
doors away actually so we'd always go
over there for um
hot chocolate soup with whipping cream
for breakfast what is hot chocolate is
hot chocolate soup just hot chocolate or
is it like a thin
soup of chocolate it's like high sugar
oh my gosh yeah which is like
i mean it's like a nice chocolate soup
like why does that sound like that yeah
why does everything in german sound so
angry
and that's what is hot say hot chocolate
it sounds so sweet would you like some
hot chocolate soup would say
is that with whipping cream or is with
whipped cream
i surrender not a romance language no
like if i wanted to give you a
compliment what would you i would you
say like
[Music]
i know
what was that i really like the
beautiful sexy wave in your big red
house
okay well i like that better
but i like this this was nice like that
helped me a little bit i thought maybe
that's about my hair or a roller coaster
who's rolling coaster height
wow right so if we were in german
whispering sweet nothings to each other